les enfants sortent elles pop corn et
laissez moi vous conter l'histoire du
viking de l'espace tort hodgson ce n'est
que par nos hommes ordinaires c'était un
dieu
après avoir sauvé la terre pour la 500e
voiture s'est embarqué dans un nouveau
voyage
il s'est remis en forme il a perdu son
centre est retrouvé son corps de dieu
et après tout ça mieux mais il est
finalement redevenu
seul et unique tort
vous ai parlé trop vite
[Musique]
on ex petit ami
ça fait combien de temps en 3 4 en 8 ans
7 mois et 6 jours plus ou moins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je perçois des sentiments
tu
es seul s'être qui importe aux yeux des
dieux
7e même temps
voici trop grossièrement
tous les dieux faut mourir
j'allais dire qu'est ce que tu as fait
là bas m'a beaucoup impressionné
c'était mon premier méchant
[Musique]
on n'oublie jamais sa première fois
non tu ne ressemble pas aux autres à
dieu que j'ai tué
une chose pour laquelle se battre
[Musique]
voyons voir qui tu es que ton
déguisement disparaissent d'une
pichenette
au temps fait trop comme d'habitude
on lui donne pas un coup de main or rien
de presse des raisins